Senator Marco Rubio will introduce a
bill today to help parents get paid
family leave it's called the Economic
Security for new parents Act the measure
would give parents two months of paid
leave by pulling from their future
Social Security benefits workers would
then delay taking Social Security for
three to six months when they retire the
bill would be the first new option for
families since the Family and Medical
Leave Act of 1993 that law gives
employees unpaid leave for 12 weeks to
care for a family member Senator Marco
Rubio is with us from Capitol Hill for
an interview you'll see first only here
on CBS this morning good morning senator
good morning good morning so how many
people would this affect well it depends
how many people want to take the option
let me start by explaining the why why
are we doing this because I don't
believe there's nothing we can do for
our children that's better than allowing
their parents to spend more time and be
more involved in their lives especially
from their early days I think it's wrong
and we all seen this people that work
somewhere and they have a child and
within two weeks of a cesarean section
or three weeks of giving birth have to
hurry back to work because they can't
afford to miss one paycheck in fact it's
startling how many parents particularly
first-time mothers and and people to do
sub children in their family go on
public assistance because they lose
their job and or they can't draw a
paycheck any longer so what we are doing
is we're giving people an option no
one's required to do this but everyone
will have the option of saying I'm gonna
take some of my benefits these are your
benefits not anybody else's and take a
portion of that earlier because I need
that money now though people can do that
now with 401ks we should be able to do
that was social sooner I was fascinated
to learn that it's estimated that just
over one in ten workers receives paid
family leave from their employers that's
that's not a lot and certainly people
need paid family leave why though do you
want it to come from to the Social
Security to pay for it well well I
prefer it come from the private sector
but as you just said only one out of ten
have it and and I hope that number will
grow over the years and by the way the
irony is the more money you make the
likely you are to have it and the less
money you make the less likely you are
to have it so if you're making $300,000
a year at an investment bank you
probably have paid family leave
but if you're making $40,000 a year
working for a small business who
probably can't afford to provide it you
do not have it as far as coming in from
there if somebody has a better idea
we're open to it if they have a better
idea that doesn't raise taxes we're all
open for it but I can tell you that this
is a real problem we cannot we have to
if we are serious in this country about
helping our children it begins from the
day they are born by allowing their
parents to be involved in the early days
of their lives especially and that
should not be a bankruptcy inducing
event and this is one option that we
think is pretty creative to allow people
to take their money and instead of
waiting 30 years to get some of it take
some of it earlier when they really need
it but senator isn't this really asking
working-class Americans to choose
between retirement security and caring
for a new child no ultimately right now
they don't even have a choice at all of
how they're gonna pay for their bills at
the front end most of them many people
right now if you have a child your job
is required to give you 12 weeks of paid
leave but they don't have to pay you so
you're basically going to go without any
pay for at four to eight weeks most
people can't afford that we have people
going on public assistance so this is
just an option no one is going to be
forced to do this some people will
decide they don't want to do it it
doesn't make sense for them but it's an
option that'll be available for people
that they don't have right now because
as it stands today if we do nothing
you're gonna continue to see as you just
said 9 out of 10 workers
well basically not draw any income
during that period of time and causing
real economic strain right now senator
President Trump tweeted yesterday that
Attorney General Jeff Sessions should
end the special councils Russia
investigation he's called it again a
rigged witch-hunt is that obstruction of
justice well I don't know what the legal
definition of that would be regards to
tweets I don't think that's ever been
litigated here's the bottom line I'm not
gonna spend my time here in the US
Senate waking up every morning and
responding to some tweet every day okay
I know you know that's what you guys are
paid to do and that's fine if it's
something that directive on public
policy but I'm gonna spend my time in
the US Senate working on paid family
leave I'm gonna spend my time in the US
Senate fighting against you know the
efforts of the Chinese to overtake us
and they drove a political stage I'm
going to spend my time fighting for the
people of Florida and on issues that are
important and when something big comes
up that needs to be addressed well
address it my view
my views of the Muller investigation are
clear I think that he should be allowed
to finish his work that all the truth
come out and that the truth is going to
be good for the president and good for
America that remains my view and the
president has a different view that
certainly that's his right and and and
you guys can ask them about it you can
ask the White House about it all of our
intelligence agencies have made clear
that they believe that the Russians
tried to interfere in our past election
and that they are still trying to do the
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates has warned about this
interference but you voted against
election security funding yesterday why
because we've already provided a ton of
money on election security most of it
hasn't even started getting paid yet so
it's not even the states wouldn't even
able to spend that money they wouldn't
know what to spend it on they've barely
even begun to spend the money that was
just given to them
a few months ago so if more is needed
next year will provide more but there I
can tell you for example the state of
Florida initially wasn't even going to
apply for the money available right now
because they couldn't spend it between
now and November so the money that we've
already appropriated is the money that
was based on a professional assessment
of what the needs were from a national
level and that money was appropriated if
an additional amount is necessary in the
future we will provided but there is no
outcry from States saying they need more
money they haven't even begun to spend
the money they have now most of them
haven't even carried out an assessment
of what they're going to need over the
next is four to six months much less
begin to spend it on your future we're
doing it that's it very well because
here's why every county is different you
know elections in this country are not
run by central organizations that run at
the county level some counties are
further and head than others some don't
need any help they've got it covered
many others do not and and they're going
through the process of it it's something
to be concerned about no doubt but just
throwing it this is nothing but it's not
to be able to say well thank you for
providing the money we're going to file
an amendment to provide more money to
make it look like you don't care all
right so you're not real
Senator Marco Rubio thanks so much for
being with us this morning thank you